[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre émission dédiée à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 20 avril
les beaux jours sont revenus une
occasion d'en profiter pendant les
vacances pour faire un tour à la ferme
de viltain la clayette a rouvert après
sa pause hivernale
au programme ramassage de tulipes des
réalisations de madeleine nous en
parlerons avec des métiers des
croustilles responsable de la ferme des
ateliers do it yourself à bois d'arcy
avec adeline apprenez à réaliser vous
même vos créations
nous avons découvert comment fabriquer
un lapin en pompe une activité à faire
en famille
partez à la découverte de la mare et de
ses habitants le parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse vous emmène
dans une réserve naturelle un espace
pour protéger la biodiversité mélanie
poquet nous parlera de cette visite pour
les petits curieux c'est un symbole de
pouvoir depuis des siècles le cheval
représente le rendant ces illustrations
un lien entre l'arrêt l'animal qui fait
l'objet d'une exposition à versailles
elle se tient dans la galerie des
affaires étrangères de la bibliothèque
centrale jusqu'au 7 juillet le parcours
permet de suivre l'évolution de l'image
du cheval depuis l'antiquité on a fait
quelques quelques 1,6 sur l'antiquité
notamment en tant que objets
d'inspiration notre pour le pouvoir de
louis xiv par exemple on est allé
jusqu'à nos jours grâce au prêt que
bartabas nous a fait de sa selle qui a
été conçu par hermès et
nous sommes permis des clins d'oeil
créatifs à savoir les fameux carré de la
maison hermès qui s'inspire d'oeuvre qui
peuvent être d'ailleurs dans nos
collections ou dans les collections
provenant de saint émile hermès et qui
nous montre en fait une sorte de super
position à la fois artistiques
politiques
[Musique]
le soleil est revenu et la cueillette de
la ferme de viltain a repris du service
tulipe salade et bientôt iris et
courgettes sont accueillir tous les
jours de la semaine pendant les vacances
des ateliers madeleine sont proposés
pour les plus jeunes plus de détails
avec notre invité patrick jacques de
dixmude pour les images
[Musique]
nous sommes à la ferme de viltain à jouy
en josas et plus précisément à la
cueillette
elle a ouvert ses portes après la pause
hivernale guillemette des courtilles
responsable de la ferme de viltain est
avec nous bonjour alors ça y est le
soleil est au rendez vous on peut le
voir ici on peut venir ramasser soi même
de nombreuses variétés de fruits et de
légumes c'est un grand jardin potager de
50 hectares qui a rouvert du coup pour
la belle saison tout à fait tout à fait
depuis 7 avril
on est ouvert et on prie vous propose
les premiers les premières fleurs et les
premiers légumes de la nuit alors les
premières fleurs justement les voix
d'arnaud en ce sens les tulipes un
énorme champ de tulipes donc pendant les
pendant le mois d'avril elle sont à
l'honneur une cinquantaine de variétés
différentes à ce que pouvaient nous les
présenter tout à fait donc on a des
variétés précoces et des variétés demi
saison et des variétés tardives avec
différentes formes et couleurs donc des
jaunes des rouges
enfin vous voyez toutes les couleurs
qu'on peut avoir et déforme tout simple
ou bien dans clés ou bien en fleur de
lys ou bien double si comme des fleurs
de pivoine donc là c'est vraiment le
moment d'en profiter un pic après au
moins deux mois de mai ce livre a trop
chaud il y en aura plus du coin oui il
faut profiter venir tout de suite tout
de suite et c'est très beau voyez c'est
et c'est la période des vacances de
printemps pour les enfants donc c'est
une bonne sortie familiale
on trouve aussi des légumes donc en ce
moment beaucoup de poireaux et de
salades c'est ça voilà des poireaux et
puis les très belles salades sous
d'auxerre quand on a planté au mois de
février et qu'il à son juste bien des
laitues des batavias et des feuilles de
chêne alors dans les prochains mois
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver
alors bientôt l'arrivée des hauts
niveaux d
les bonnes choses la rhubarbe pour faire
des tartes
ensuite il y aura des épinards ensuite
des courgettes
bien plus tard des tomates et au mois de
juin les fraises les groseilles les
cassis les conseils macro et puis fin
juin
les framboises donc l'appareil sera
vraiment le moment d'en profiter
donc pour ceux qui préfèrent peut-être
les ateliers manuels pendant les
vacances de printemps les enfants
peuvent aussi en profiter pour fabriquer
des madeleines vous proposer des
ateliers
oui tout à fait ce vendredi puis lundi
mardi et mercredi de la semaine
prochaine
des ateliers à 13h30 ou est 16 heures où
les enfants de 4 à 12 ans peuvent
apprendre avec un jeune étudiant à faire
des madeleines et en même temps on fait
un tour au niveau 2 les tables pendant
que les madeleines cuisent on va faire
voir les petits veaux voir la salle de
traite et ensuite il ya un goûter
organisé où les enfants mangeront des
des madeleines et du jus de pomme
alors comment fait on pour s'inscrire à
ces ateliers donc c'est eux qui
travaillent ce sont les enfants qui
travaillent parce que les adultes sont
invités également oui les enfants tout à
fait les parents peuvent tout à fait
parents et grands parents peuvent bien
sûr assisté et donc l'inscription se
fait par téléphone ou sur place et le
téléphone de la ferme ses 2 01 39 56 38
alors justement la salle de traite un
salon l'endroit crucial pour la ferme de
viltain puisque c'est le lait 1 qui a
fait beaucoup la renommée de cet
établissement de cette ferme aussi tout
à fait et tous les jours de l'année on
peut venir voir la traite des vaches et
les petits veaux donc toute la journée
et ensuite le moment de la traite a lieu
de 15h45 à 17h45 et chaque mercredi
on propose une visite guidée complète de
les tables avec des explications sur la
vie des vaches leur nourriture leur
reproduction
et c'est une visite aux voix vraiment où
l'alimentation et ça se finit par une
dégustation des frais
la ferme a toujours eu à coeur de
continuer à proposer justement ce type
d'atelier de rapprocher des enfants avec
l'agriculture
le potager voilà tout ce genre de choses
d'environnement c'est vraiment important
pour pour d'établissement oui tout à
fait mes parents au dès que son nom
s'est installé à viltain faisait les
visites et ensuite c'est nous qui avons
continué les visites aussi bien de
l'étape que de la cueillette et c'est
important de savoir que les enfants
apprennent d'où viennent tous qui vont
auront dans leur assiette et donc exprès
dans notre établi notre salle de traite
et contre salle de traite est conçu pour
qu'on puisse avoir un balcon et voir par
dessus la la traite en train de se
dérouler et que les enfants ensuite
aussi par un balcon voile et les petits
veaux et c'est essentiel de savoir que
voilà d'où viennent les choses et
certains enfants sont tous surpris de
savoir que le lait vient des vaches ils
pensent parfois que ces faits comme
certains sodas dans une grande usine
donc ça c'est une découverte
donc c'est tellement basique on veut que
continuer est ouvert tous les jours
librement donc une vraie tradition le
livre les vrais métiers de la ferme en
tout cas à découvrir à la ferme de
viltain merci guillemette des courtils
donc n'hésitez pas à venir vous inscrire
auprès de la ferme de viltain pour
participer aux ateliers madeleine et
vous régaler et comme les beaux jours
sont revenus profitez-en également pour
faire un tour à la cueillette
elle est ouverte tous les jours de 10h à
18h30 des ateliers pour créer soi-même
sa décoration les ateliers ferment
d'adeline lancé depuis janvier propose
des activités manuelles nous l'avons
rencontré mélanie poquet pour les images
nous savons à bois d'arcy avec adeline
gober laurent qui a lancé depuis janvier
ces ateliers do it yourself des
activités pour apprendre à faire soi
même ses bijoux sa décoration et
aujourd'hui on
apprendre à faire un lapin en pompon
[Musique]
bonjour hanouna bonjour comment vous est
venue l'idée de créer vos ateliers
on va déjà toujours bricoler à depuis je
suis tout petit avec ma maman j'ai
toujours fait tout à la main avec
l'écologie etc qui me touchent un peu
j'en suis ni au recyclage et donc je
pars de ce que j'ai à la maison pour
avoir des idées pour bricoler voilà il
vous reste des pelote de laine ou pour
affaire voilà pendant pour exactement
ces partis alors c'est quoi la première
étape première étape va choisir sa laine
[Musique]
en fait on a découpé will allen parce
que normalement les tenues à l'intérieur
on va découper voilà tout le monde mais
en fait c'est là qu'on va voir tous les
poils qui vont se faire voilà peu après
on réunira avec la laine
autour on serrera bien pour que la boue
la bresse d'accord ok
[Musique]
et on va les attacher tard il n'y a pas
de simplement ya rien de secret et de
miraculeux on fais juste attention qui
assemble voilà encore du lapin
donc le lapin est presque fini il manque
juste en est on va faire mener avec la
feutrine rouge c'est ça donc voilà je
terminais mon latin donc deux de pompons
un gros un petit une que deux oreilles
deux yeux et à la fin le petit nez ça
c'est un atelier qu'on peut faire du
coup à tout âge avec ses enfants
c'est ça avec un sou parents qui
viennent ici par le saint amand et donc
d'en proposer régulièrement notamment
pendant les vacances d'avril
exactement et sinon aller mercredi dans
les studios
voilà donc on au rendez vous avec kazim
pour pouvoir réaliser vos créations des
lapins emportant des bijoux ou de la
décoration
merci beaucoup de nous merci à vous
[Musique]
pour cette deuxième semaine de vacances
de printemps si vous mettiez au vert si
vous n'êtes pas très ferme ou cueillette
mélanie vous propose d'aller découvrir
un parc bonjour mais l'ami jean camille
et on va même au parc naturel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse alors
pour les vacances et équipe ont concocté
un programme qui est destiné à toute la
famille un moyen de se reconnecter avec
le milieu naturel puisque je suis en ile
de france il ya aussi du verre pour la
bienvenue tout à l'heure au pnr c'est
l'abréviation du parc on trouve trois
réserves naturelles et petite
explication sur ce que c'est une réserve
naturelle régionale en fait c'est un
outil de préservation de la biodiversité
donc qui ce qui se situe sur un site
naturel sur lequel on a identifié un
patrimoine naturel remarquable et donc
le classement en réserve naturelle
régionale va permettre de protéger de
pérenniser ce patrimoine naturel et ce
patrimoine peut se découvrir mardi 24
avril cette fois les petits curieux vont
pas se font partir à la découverte des
marais de leurs habitants dans la
réserve
val et coteaux de saint rémy les
chevreuse et vous pourrez y voir des
libellules des tritons et des
salamandres alors l'animation s'adresse
aux enfants âgés de 7 à 12 ans il faut
obligatoirement un adulte accompagnateur
pour en profiter un maximum pensez à
bien vous équiper le départ de la balade
est à 14 heures et après la nature vous
pourrez aussi faire un petit bond
historique avec la visite du château de
la madeleine et une faune ne forteresse
fondée il ya presque mille ans alors il
y à un livret jeu qui permet de visiter
d'une autre manière le château et vous
êtes accompagné durant toute cette
visite par guy le premier seigneur de
chevreuse remonter au temps des
chevaliers et découvrir les habitants
démarrent toutes les informations sont
disponibles sur le site internet de la
haute vallée de chevreuse merci mélanie
pour ce rendez vous le 7 8 loisirs est
maintenant terminée nous espérons que
vous avez fait le plein d'idées sorties
en famille ou entre amis on se retrouve
en dhr du prochain pour un nouveau
numéro et d'ici là je vous souhaite de
très belles vacances
[Musique]